que s'est-il passé dans ce foyer pour
personnes handicapées du Nord-Ouest tout
rangeau un surveillant de nuit et
suspecté de viol et agressions sexuelle
sur trois femmes des femmes considérées
comme vulnérables placé en garde à vue
puis libérer le suspect a été mise à
pied le temps de l'enquête Lucas Chopin
Ambillou comme une paisible située à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de Tours et le
théâtre d'une bien triste à faire en
effet c'est derrière moi dans ce foyer
destiné à l'accueil de personnes
atteintes d'un handicap mental que de
terribles accusations ont vu le jour
trois résidentes jugées vulnérables
disent avoir suivi viols et agressions
sexuelle de la part d'un surveillant de
nuit employé par l'association qui
administre le foyer selon nos confrères
de la Nouvelle République à l'origine de
la révélation de l'affaire l'un des
derniers actes dénoncés remontraient à
seulement quelques jours le misanthose
lui a été interpellé et placé en garde à
vue ce mercredi 19 juillet une garde à
vue qui aurait été levée en l'absence
d'éléments probants l'homme a été mise à
pied le temps de l'enquête confié pour
l'heure au gendarmes de la cellule de
lutte contre les atteintes aux personnes
de la compagnie de Tours des
investigations ADN et informatiques sont
en cours pour le moment l'administration
du foyer n'a pas donné suite à nos
sollicitations